Two sources of difficulty, when using your
product, are due to the lack of discoverability
and feedback, knowing what to do, then
wondering what happened. These two difficulties result from
the huge gulf between a person's goal and the means of achieving them, this is
called the gulf of execution. There's also the
gulf between assessing the state of the world,
and trying to determine if that state
matches the initial goal, and this is called
the gulf of evaluation. Figuring out what
actions are possible, during the gulf of execution,
is all about discoverability. And knowing what
just happened during the gulf of evaluation is
about feedback. Ever buy a new product and then not know how to work it?
Well, likely because it lacks discoverability. Ever
stand at an elevator or pedestrian traffic light?
Pushing the button, but not knowing if the
system noticed, so you push over and over
again, that's because of lack of feedback. The role of the designer is to help
people bridge the two gulfs, making the possible
actions discoverable and providing feedback along the way.